un seul vaccin vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé
alors qu'en italie le coronavirus a vidé
les rues de ces passants et
consommateurs la france se prépare à une
situation similaire les secteurs de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration font
déjà face à une baisse sévère des
réservations et de l'affluence 22% de
manque à gagner dans la région au de
france par exemple
selon une enquête de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie dans le morbihan
ce sont 13 % des entreprises
touristiques du département qui ont dû
fermer temporairement mais avec les
quarantaine et l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 100 personnes
le coc vide 19 va désormais impacter
directement tout un pan de l'économie
des loisirs
à commencer par le monde du septième art
les sorties de plusieurs blockbusters
ont d'ores et déjà été suspendu
à l'instar du remake live de mulan des
studios disney ou des nouveaux mutants
produit par marvel réduisant d'autant la
programmation des cinémas de l'hexagone
des cinémas dont les salles devraient
par ailleurs probablement fermer les
unes après les autres afin d'éviter la
propagation du virus
idem pour les musées qui ont annoncé ce
vendredi fermé leurs portes jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
à paris le louvre le musée d'orsay
l'atelier des lumières ou encore le
château de versailles n'accueilleront
plus leurs dizaines de milliers de
visiteurs quotidiens au cours des
prochaines semaines
même les parcs d'attractions ne sont pas
épargnés à disneyland paris les
visiteurs profitent ici du dernier jour
d'ouverture du parc avec trois employés
testé positif aux coronavirus le site se
passera de visiteurs jusqu'à fin mars
par principe de précaution selon les
calculs du secrétariat d'état au
tourisme
la filière devrait perdre 10 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires sur les
seules quatre premiers mois de l'année
soit plus de 1% du produit intérieur
brut national sur cette période
[Musique]